بعد اربعه ايام على ارتكاب جريمه التي راح
ضحيتها الطالب السعوديه الوليد الغريبي
اعتقلت الشرطه الامريكيه المتهمه نيكون
ميري روترز التي اعترفت على الفورد
بارتكابها الجريمه وتم توجيه تهم القتل
والسلب والسطو لها
اتصلنا بيكارديس صاحبه المنزل الذي شهد
جريمه القتل وطلبنا منها الظهور معانا على
الكاميرا واعجبتنا انه نزولا لرغبه عائله
الغربي لا تستطيع مشاركتنا اي تفاصيل
لا استطيع ان اعطي تفاصيل والد وليد طلب
مني ذلك تفاصيل القضيه لا زالت غامضه حتى
اللحظه ما هي دوافع الجريمه كيف حذرت لها
كيف استخدمت مواد التنظيف للتخلص من اثار
جريمهمتها وهل ساعدها احد كل هذه الاسئله
بانتظار انتهاء التحقيقات مع المتهمه
جريمه مروعه هزت الاوساط العربيه والجاليه
السعوديه في الولايات المتحده ففي رحله
بحثه عن العلم والاجتهاد من اجل المعرفه
سقط الطالب الوليد الغريبي ضحيه غدرا وكل
ذنبه نخوته لمساعده الجميع بحسب شهاده من
عرفه عن قرب سليمان العربيه واشنطن